j'ai lu ici et là des articles où on me
on prétendait que
j'arrivais tard le soir à la rédaction
un peu dans la pénombre avec une clé USB
reçu de je ne sais qui pour faire passer
des images sans que personne s'en
aperçoit c'est faux
archi faux
et c'est mieux connaître le
fonctionnement d'une chaîne de
télévision que d'affirmer une telle
chose
[Musique]
ce que je j'appelle un processus normal
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait moi quand je
recevais des images provenant de
Monsieur Duthion par exemple ces images
étaient visionnées
elles étaient montées pas par mes soins
elles étaient montées elles étaient
ensuite validées
pas par mes soins encore une fois
et ensuite elle pouvait être diffusée
sachant que
une image quelle qu'elle soit
qui n'a pas reçu la validation et encore
une fois c'est pas moi qui valide les
images une image qui pour être diffusée
qui n'a pas reçu la validation ne peut
pas être diffusé sur BFM TV je n'ai
jamais rien fait en douce
je n'ai jamais rien caché à personne de
mon travail je n'ai jamais
au grand jamais travailler autrement
quand toute transparence
vis-à-vis de ma rédaction vis-à-vis de
moi-même ou vis-à-vis du public et
finalement les seules fois où vous avez
eu recours à des images extérieures
c'est celle de Monsieur Duthion ça
paraît un peu étrange c'est à dire que
finalement pour les sujets où vous aviez
effectivement une discussion là la
bibliothèque de BFM TV ne suffisait pas
et pour tous les autres sujets que vous
évoquiez en off là la bibliothèque
d'images de BFM TV suffisait vous
informer cette commission que Monsieur
Duthion nous acclamez transmis de
reportages clés en main d'éléments clés
en main de de d'image de contenu que
vous auriez
servillement entre guillemets
reproduit à l'antenne il ne m'a jamais
fourni de textes clés en main comme j'ai
pu le lire ici ou là j'ai toujours
moi-même
écris mes textes
[Musique]
il faut bien le dire monsieur
grâce à l'affaire mbarquis
qui l'aura finalement construite
lui-même est de toute pièce au risque
infinés
de jeter le discrédit sur l'enquête
forbidden stories tout entière qui ne se
résume pourtant pas et fort heureusement
aux seuls accusations portées
injustement contre moi